As cancer cells die off, how does our body get rid of them? How are they expelled?
So cancer, when cancer cells die, they die through a process of apoptosis. So apoptosis is normal
program cell death. I have several blog posts about this. I think I call them apoptosis. One of
the apoptosis two or one with some videos about it. So cancer cells can also die through
abnormal ways, pathological cell death. Typically that's how cancer cells die when you are exposed
to chemotherapy. So chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent, it's a poison, and anytime a cell is poisoned,
it dies through a pathological death through a cell lysis. So the cell lysis means it breaks apart,
it bursts through an oxidative process. That's the danger of oxidizing agents that you're exposed
to chemicals and additives, colorings, flavorings, all these chemicals that are diet, they can,
they act as oxidizing agents, they act as poisons and they cause cell lysis. So if you
drink a poison, how does somebody die? If they drink poison, you've seen it in spy movies,
they drink a poison and they kill over their dead. Well, if you drink a oxidizing agent that's
a very, very strong oxidizing agent, it causes immediate cell death, immediate cell lysis,
and you could die quite rapidly. Well, that's what chemotherapy does, it causes cell lysis.
Of course, it's an immediate cell death, it's going into the bloodstream and you're hoping that it's
taken up by cells that are more metabolically active, a cancer cells, and it is. It is taken up by cells
that are more metabolically active. That's how chemotherapy works. Unfortunately, your hair
follicles are more metabolically active and your immune system cells are more metabolically active.
So you will damage your immune system. That's why they need to check it. Every time you go in for
chemotherapy visit, they need to do a CBC, see what your white blood cell count is before they can
administer the chemotherapy because if it's too low, another dose of chemotherapy could kill the patient.
So I'm going to make sure that your immune system has recovered enough since the last
infusion in order to give you another infusion of a poison. So it makes it sound like it's a horrible
thing, which it is in a way, but cancer cells will uptake that poison. More readily than a healthy cell will,
therefore, will kill cancer cells, thicker than it will kill the healthy cell, though, but lingers
in the body, your will kill healthy cells as well. It does cause apoptosis sometimes, but more
commonly it causes cell lysis within the pathological cell death. It's a process of the cell and that's
a breaky to part of the cell. So in the case of cell lysis, the cell just explodes. It breaks apart
and all this cell exudate is all over the place. So that is, those are called endotoxins, endomines
within toxins. It's not something from outside of the body, it's toxins from inside of the body,
aka the cell components that have just exploded all over the extracellular space, and the immune system
has to deal with it. It can fire an immune response, which is going to be just an inflammatory type
response, be a histamine response, other chemo-kind responses, which could actually cause more problems,
more inflammatory cytokines to the area, not necessarily T cells that are going to kill cancer cells,
but more inflammation and fluid that is going to actually hinder a T cell response to be able to kill
cancer cells. It's a negative side of chemo-therapy. So that has to be carried into the lymph system
and then through the bloodstream and basically detoxified. So that's supposed to detoxification pathways.
By the way, a cell dies doing natural methods or using the right machine or using herbal therapies.
Those are stimulated immune response to kill a cell through what's called a normal program cell
or apoptosis. An apoptosis is not a shattering of the cell. It's not a lysis of the cell. It's a
recycling of the cell material. It goes through a whole process of what's called blebs,
basically enfolding upon itself. It's basically the cell is enfolding and just kind of
breaking into pieces and then your body recycles that and reuses that. Therefore, when you do
right therapy or natural type therapies that are not oxidative therapies, now there are some
natural therapies that are oxidative, but if you do natural type therapies that are not oxidative,
they're immune stimulant type therapies. You don't get the perksymer type reactions.
Technically, one of the ill feelings post chemo-therapy is perksymer reaction. Perksymer reaction is
defined by what you have produced that excess amount of endotoxins that overwhelm your body and make
you feel quite ill. You can feel a lot of malaise, a lot of fatigue. You just feel ill. You're
overwhelming. You're liver detox pathways. So you're becoming toxic. So, you know, chemotherapy
makes you toxic because of the drug itself, but it's making you toxic because of the endotoxins
that it's producing through cell lysis of both cancer cells and healthy cells. So how are
cancer cells expelled? It depends on how they do. Hope that explained that. More details you could
look up apoptosis on our blog.